we're thrilled to have in studio the
founder co-founder of big three
basketball on the CEO of big three
basketball going back no doubt to their
Raider days Ice Cube and Amy Trask
together good to see you oh thank you
good to be here thanks for having us and
Steve Smith has taken a Chris lawsuit
over the Chris command center good to
see you right there he told me what
you're on you're on over there oh ok
show some team ready to sign him up oh
this look I mean no company offers you
got Steve before the drafter four or
five teams that call my agent and see if
I was still for real and then I had
another team contact me through somebody
else to kind of fill me out but no I'm
good how many injuries you think it's
going to take and I'm not trying to you
know how many introduction back and the
league for you to get more calls
um I mean I'll be on info Network so
I've seen before I can see when the
injuries happen I can see them but the
scrolling at the bottom of screen
they're going to Haley you're falling
when that happens like somebody goes
down and been bowling yeah Steve come
play for us man we just lost our number
two our number three guy well
technically I have not showed up for
drug testers so I would be suspended if
I try to reinstate well I mean you would
know that ins and outs of that policy
better than most up for the next degree
doctor he is just said you know I don't
want to give him a little advice to sort
of just you know maybe want to Ratchet
back on that on air alright I'm not I
just mean in as far as though I'm not to
do it I'm not done yeah he's done that's
the that's the purpose of I'm not saying
walking around being wrong here I prefer
not to be in the system of anything
other than NFL Network Bill Parcells
said when when you don't want to hit him
no more and you know what you damn sure
don't want them to hit you no more hmm
you know you know it's true and I will
say that over that almost 30 years in
the league players no and the team knows
when you reach that point you're done
well Steve is just bored that ain't the
case with him oh I'm not suggesting I
agree yeah man yeah I got I got four
kids at home they need their daddy
and you know I was living in Baltimore
over three years right attend college
missed a lot of soccer volleyball games
and so now I'm part of the paperclip cut
gang yeah yeah
get a pan cook you know what I panting
your silver and black right now I'm
gonna make some happy delivery phone
call you're crazy phone call me I could
see you they got enough flour receivers
oh no no no no no no we need well and I
guess to turn it to the big three it's
interesting you have given through the
big three retired NBA players former
royal pardon me former NBA players a
place to go and shine and all out and
ball out and 15 what was the exact
audience that showed up deliver 15,000
and they were before their feet and the
level of competition in these games is
ferocious 15,000 177 but whose game you
are I like it and it was just you could
you could sense it obviously when it
happened on Sunday I was seeing all the
videos and photos of people tweeting
about it and putting it on social media
and watching on fs1 last night I mean
that was a and I told you this off very
spectacle oh yeah and this is
entertainment that you're clearly
selling and people are buying and the
players are into it how how did you get
how did you do that
essentially well uh it's a thing where
you know we we felt like as fans you
know that's how I come into it of course
I know you got to put the right business
plan and people in place but I felt like
it was something that I would want to
see if it came to my time and from there
you know we just started to see how we
can build this for real not you know
play with it not you know kind of mess
with it but go for it and and put these
guys on on the right stage where we know
that they will perform like you saw them
do Sunday
I mean Monday night so it's just about
from there putting the right people in
place and getting them on board
and you know open yourself up to their
visions for the league open yourself up
to their expertise open yourself up to
their you know
mentality and with the right people and
the right kind of you know know-how and
and and you know kind of you put your
foot in there man and you go for it and
we are great people a muse here and we
couldn't be here without her enriched
those players came out ready to ball and
they fed off the excitement of that
fifteen thousand one hundred and seventy
seven crowd and you know they engage our
players and our coaches engage with the
fans during the game which
differentiates us from other leagues and
to see two little kids approach Charles
Oakley who is coaching a game at
halftime and have him turn to them and
sign their you know autograph their
basketballs during a game was
magnificent our players are engaged with
the kids and the fans our coaches are
engaged and we're going to give as you
said a spectacle it's going to be a
different experience but ultimately the
game is good those men are there to
compete and to compete as hard as they
can and people are not used to seeing
the basketball festival like you know
and we have one we have you wear one
ticket gets you four games and you got
to be there you know big three is
must-see well in terms of that a me
trashcan and and ice cube here in studio
you need somebody to be for the lack of
it a phrase your Joe Namath to say I'm
in yes and then you also need somebody
once they see it's happening to say I
want in because I see it's fun and
that's happening now so let's let me ask
you who is who was your Joe Namath who
was the one Allen Iverson how did you
get well I mean he was our most famous
but you know I gotta back up some I got
a backup to Kenyon Martin I got to back
up to Chauncey Billups and Gary Payton
and Iceman and I know okay dr. Jay and
Clyde to glide
um Steven Jackson you know these are
guys Jermaine O'Neal - and uh
Rashard Lewis I don't want to leave
anybody out because these are the guys
if I didn't have in that first church I
would and you know I wouldn't have been
able to get AI who saw that oh we got
something serious brewing over here did
you personally reach out to uh first
time and well how was that received for
just wasn't sure if he was ready to play
and show it already well just getting
back in the basketball okay and you know
and doing what it takes to to get itself
you know ready to play and he wasn't
sure and then he got sure he we called
him back after we got a little further
down the road and asked him and he said
y'all I'm all-in and I'm ready to go and
it's because we started to create this
movement and you know it's going really
like I say snowball into something great
there's nine more dates to go and the
big three season that just started at
Barclays center
who is the let me take a break and we'll
come back in 60 seconds you'll tell me
you've already gotten calls from people
saying I wanted Oh during the game we
had former NBA guys and current NBA guys
in the crowd kind of Sant I want in I
want into that game all right now what
names I want names like okay it's called
60 seconds from now it's called a tease
even if you're not going to give me a
name Oh gotcha gotcha I call the tease
I'm kind of creative spectacles I got a
few names for you okay I chase cube and
Amy Trask
with Steve Smith part of the front here
on the Rich Eisen show back in 66
you
the big three schedule that just
launched at Barclays Center in Brooklyn
New York for ice cube and a me Trask who
are here in studio for another segment
moves on you ready for this Steve Smith
are you ready Sunday Charlotte yeah yay
North Carolina
yeah man North cackle egg I'll be I got
to show up are you gonna be there
yes okay there you go you heard it we're
gonna show it out now I expect North
Carolina to be taping have you are you
gonna join us in Staples
that's 1,000% okay good and I'm in I
mean I'll bring my kids my kids will
bring the dog a little service jacket
tada you know you're talking my language
in my living language no hey Hudson's
then Hudson's in my kids will come here
if you'll be my service dog for the
night because I could use the calming
influence
okay very good I like it uh have you
reached out to Jordan MJ had to do it
show up be there oh I would love for him
to come you know I mean sure you're
going right you're right there in North
Carolina yeah I would love for him to
come I thought you meant to play oh well
sure that's you he probably would if you
could
well you know he would he would dominate
I would just you can't put anything past
without a doubt but uh man I would love
oh that would be a dream come true if MJ
yeah bless us cam his presence and
everybody there would treat him like a
king I know it's his building we'll
treat him better than they treat him in
his own building that's on Sunday and
you'll be there too Steve all right be
there okay
plus plus how many how many do you need
what's this oh oh you are oh oh oh oh
you broke my checkbook up I'm gonna get
you I'm a gay you know me too don't know
don't do Eric Dickerson now don't go god
yeah I'm three max and before four get
that for Steve what are you making ready
card is not to credit claim okay how
about this scratch the card honestly
yeah I'll take five and I play for
myself but I need Wow I need my rocks
and that's sunny my fire don't put me up
in there don't worry boy don't you worry
that careful
trust me you'll have the best ones in
the house you by the way
I'll answer your teeth yes Paul Pierce
so you've got power here so do is plug
in the arena they interviewed him on
camera Thank You Sean
we had a chairs and some shoes here
price jumped me non-stop you can't do
but by the way it and you know in all
seriously as you know that's that's
that's the wind that you see players
former players right former players want
it because they see it's fun they
already want it's a unique combination
rich of fun you're right and exciting
you're right but it's also a good game
horrible and the level of competition
look we had a practice game what a month
or so ago down in Long Beach and the
level of intensity
first of all Gary Payton who may be the
only person who could go one-on-one with
me trash talking to watch him coach at
that practice game and watch the level
of intensity these guys brought to a
practice which was geared towards
broadcast issues of just really
tremendous
so speaking of broadcast are there plans
I know you were just technically
crawling before your walking and jogging
what have you are there plans to go live
it's supposed to post produce it for the
next night with fs1 or what do you got
whoa you mean this year whatever all of
the lawrence under this line though
eventually we want to get there i think
we caught everybody off guard this year
you know we got into to it a little late
you know in january a lot of people had
their summer slots already slotted
players and buildings you mean row
broadcasting bracket us okay yeah so you
know the window was monday night but we
felt that it was a better event for the
fans on sunday afternoon so we felt like
it's a better ticket for the fans on
sunday not bringing my kids on afternoon
Monday night I'm not paying my kid
exactly it's on the monday night it was
just a little harder and when we go live
who love to go live in the day on Sunday
and this year our championship will be
live we're playing our championship in
Vegas it will be live and it'll be on
Fox okay
and if you go live if you don't mind me
making a suggestion if you go live you
need a five-second delay on ramp
as your sideline let's be about a decade
you need that five seconds like now a
rich to do you know they think I need a
five second delay also so I hope that I
know already I've read your book so
Rappaport actually was on Dan Patrick
show earlier today and you saying that
the finale of the season in Vegas that
you and dr. Dre should perform together
for the big finale would you be up for
something like that and NWA reunion at a
halftime of this event would you be mad
or something like that I haven't even
thought about it one on the Scylla
I'm worried about setting the stage for
the players to perform and have a great
season so you're saying that and there's
a chance I there's always a chance okay
but Wow II you know the thing is this
it's really all about the players and
and then getting a chance to show you
what they still got I mean we're char
Lewis had 27 points DeShawn Stevenson
game-winner and how about Billy
best line of the night lights are on and
I don't see no competition oh and how
about bidding sinking the two fours
exactly so that's what it's all about
it's all about the world getting into
these guys getting into you know the
wins the losses the players not only our
marquee players but the players that
will emerge you know Andre owns a guy
who will help the priests company win
the game you know scoring a lot of
points at the end so that's what it's
all about it's all about not IceCube but
it's all about us having you know every
monday we can enjoy these guys get down
again i get notice out of all the
photographs you were suited and booted
yeah you you came business suit tie the
whole thing who who are you wearing for
your opening night
really oh yeah really it don't matter
who I'm wearing because whatever I get
in it's gonna look good you're like
really
you didn't think I'd ask that question
did you it took me a little bit off yeah
I like throwing curveballs no but I did
notice that that that
you dressed the CEO like the business
CEO when you stood there man oh yeah I
know that no I got B yah yeah yeah let
me tell you something I know I know
and ya partner you know I have been an
NWA fan since NWA started and I think
that this is the most sensational
musician artist musical artist actor
producer of our entire generation he's
an even better businessman and even even
better human being but what I've learned
through this is his business vision and
his business wisdom is just off the
charts well I mean again I'm not just
throwing this out there just cuz you're
my guests I mean you could tell by the
broadcast last night and 15,000 fans
showing up that every single possible
business lever that you could pull was
pulled and it's not just make this
happen
it's hard work and rolling up his sleeve
on every meeting every phone calls
things don't just roll out and that was
I've been putting in 18-hour days on
this what the hell you doing the other
eight you know I got to be a superhero I
did that math wrong now there's 26 hours
in a day when he comes in launching day
right great on television I just added
18 and eight and came up with a 26 hour
day which by the way we need when cube
said to us no sleep till Brooklyn he was
not kidding and he was not exaggerating
no sleep till Brooklyn are we allowed to
sleep now nope no sleep till Charlotte
and then Tulsa Oklahoma after that
Philadelphia yeah when Iverson and dr. J
walk in that yeah oh my goodness
gracious
they are gonna be ready that's gonna be
a lot of guys often else a lot of guys
you know they saw the life they watched
well they're gonna be ready they gonna
be ready then it's neat then you're
gonna have the playoffs in Seattle where
there's an underserved basketball
audience to say the least
yes for whom watching Durant do their
thing in Russell Westbrook when the MVP
you know with I'm not able for them to
see that that's what we're coming to to
you know bring some cheer coming to
bring some basketball cheer to Key Arena
right
without a job Gary anyones Gary Peyton's
gonna be there Rashard Lewis is a fan
favorite there and you know it's
probably a couple other guys that that
uh you know we can't wait till they get
there just doing Seattle and get it nice
standing ovations and by the way rich
what's been exciting is all the venues
reaching out to us and saying come to us
next year come to us next year
we're in ten markets this year but we've
heard from triple that number of markets
about people who want us there next year
and we we've had even internationally
people want us to you know think about
putting you know all-star tunes together
sure taking it overseas well congrats
it's it's great to see it really is I
look forward to seeing in in staples
when it arrives here on August 13th it
all culminates on the 26th in Vegas and
then this coming Sunday the big three
comes to Charlotte plus what do we
decide plus we'll have Smith Smith plus
four know I'm five and he's scratching
the card for the best possible seats
available
hey card no I'm not it's nice white it's
clear oh I think metal I cannot thank
you stickers and that you got that yeah
the chip it is made out of the chip am I
ever going to live like having added
wrong and done the math on your show no
definitely not our CEO you know she's
very smart no I know I know
I didn't count on my fingers thanks for
coming on I appreciate it you got a cube
a meat rats we're gonna wrap up this
show in a moment don't you dare move
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like that
video be sure to download our app and
I'll be sure to move week six games to
Saturday for that wedding you have to go
to